the european union and japan have so
much in common
we both promote a multilateral global
system based on rules
designed to protect and benefit all
and it is precisely because this vision
is so often challenged today that the
european union is looking to strengthen
its relationship with like-minded
partners such as japan
and this brings me to russia it is today
the most direct threat to the world
order
with a barbaric war against ukraine
and it's worrying packed with china and
their call for new
and very much arbitrary international
relations
like the european union japan
understands what is at stake here not
just ukraine's future not just europe's
future
but the future of a rules-based world
order and this makes it all the more
essential for like-minded partners like
the european union and japan to
strengthen their relations and this is
why we are here today and we have taken
some important steps forward first
we are launching today
the eu japan digital partnership second
we will use our strategic partnership
agreement
to diversify and strengthen our supply
chains third we agreed to cooperate more
intensively on infrastructure
[Music]
you